mom
no kissing
just one no sorry
i'm gonna die
you guys
listen we're totally here for kourtney
kardashian and travis barker's
commitment to pda
lots and lots of pda
it's a beautiful thing
but their kids that's another story
you guys please not french kids
no fridge kissing baby okay
the cringe fest went down on hulu's the
kardashians court and trev do what they
always do
even
at your house uh for christmas
travis and and courtney for real just
make out non-stop that's all they do
well it is 98 of the new show is that
wrong no
but when it's in front of court's
nine-year-old daughter penelope she
quickly tries to shut it down
no kissing
just one no sorry we had to what about
our certificates you gave us
what about our certificate
and later a similar moment during a
family dinner with travis's kids he
shares with his ex-wife shayna mookler
atiana landon and alabama our children
come first and their happiness and as
long as you know the kardashians are
good to my kids you know that's all that
matters to me as a mom you know as long
as they're happy and then you know
that's that's the key penelope is there
with her younger brother seven-year-old
reign and like his sister he gets pretty
grossed out
i'm gonna die
you guys
french again
[Music]
okay
sorry to break it to you guys but you
better get used to it because mom and
dad are officially married and the pda
is probably not stopping anytime soon
the pair tied the nod at the santa
barbara courthouse on sunday but it
wasn't the wedding a source confirms to
et that it was just a formality to make
things legally official before a bigger
bash
our source says the barkers will
celebrate their nuptials in italy we're
just you know living our best lives and
yeah
but before kravis goes big in italy and
before they got hitched on the
california coast they got in some
practice last month exchanging vows in
an unofficial ceremony in sin city
officiated by yeah an elvis impersonator
you did a practice run on the wedding
congratulations thank you so
when is the real wedding and what will
that look like because we're really
seeing your love story with your soul
mate on the new show we don't know yet
big small wedding we don't know
one thing's for sure we'll be glued to
our screens as kravis's love story
continues to unfold it's all i could
ever want an eyewitness at the santa
barbara ceremony tells e.t that a camera
crew was present for the big moment
so chances are good that the big
celebration will also be documented
come on chris don't let us down
i love that
the episodes are more a little bit
documentary style and i think that you
have a real insight into what the girls
are doing not only what you see
in the press or whatever but what's
really happening behind the scenes
[Music]